- When I was 20, I stopped
talking for like three months.
I didn't know what was wrong.
It was dark.
The only time I used
my voice was at night.
I would walk by myself and I would sing.
I never sang before then.
I needed to listen to
the voice inside of me
to find out what my purpose was.
I decided, I remember I was
like, "I'm gonna be a singer."
(upbeat music)
I'm Lizzo; I am a rapper; I'm
a singer; I'm a songwriter;
and I live in Los Angeles, California..
Once I decided to become a singer,
my mission became very clear to me.
My music is activism
because my mere existence
as a musician is activism,
and I want you to use the song
to activate you to make
the world a better place.
You don't see black women, you
don't see big girls like me,
and that should change.
I wanna see tons of plus size pop stars.
I wanna see black girl magic.
I just wanna see us way more.
Imagine a heaven where all
of the angels and goddesses
are thick and voluptuous
and just scrumptious.
Growing up in Detroit, I was raised
very, very, very strict Pentecostal.
Couldn't go to the movies,
couldn't listen to secular music.
It was the devil.
♫ Can't stop till I believe
♫ That I'm perfect in my own mind
When you're finding your voice,
you can't have any
restrictions on yourself
and you can't have any fears,
so I had to let go of all
of that to find my voice,
and she a little ratchet, but
my family still loves her.
- Give me one more and I'll let you go.
- Okay, I’ma turn myself up.
I wouldn't be here if I didn't
stop talking for three months.
tell myself to be a singer.
Everything else actually just
started falling into place.
That's what finding your
purpose is all about.
The universe conspires with you.
(upbeat music)